cette résidence accueille une
soixantaine de personnes en perte
d'autonomie obtenir une place ici peut
prendre des mois
parce que la liste d'attentes est très
longue mais les mains liées on peut
penser toutes les places sont prises ici
la maison d'amy lee est ce qu'on appelle
une ressource intermédiaire une
résidence privée mais subventionné par
le gouvernement qui compte sur ses
ressources intermédiaires pour
contribuer à désengorger les hôpitaux 25
millions de dollars pour mettre à la
disposition de notre réseau 350 places
de ressources intermédiaires et des
places d'hébergement 350 places
d'hébergement d'ici deux mois pour
désengorger les hôpitaux et les urgences
en sortant les patients qui n'ont plus
besoin de soins spécialisés ont les v6
essentiellement à la grande région de
montréal avec dans runes sud
pourquoi parce qu'on a constaté qu'il
l'a il y en avait deux nouvelles
disponibles nous on n'aurait pas été
informé d'un ange ministre pas du tout
les ressources intermédiaires disent ne
pas avoir été mise dans le coup elles
seraient remplies à presque 100 %
difficile donc de créer des dizaines de
places en quelques semaines
surtout dans le contexte d'une pénurie
de préposés aux bénéficiaires
il faut le planifier nantes à court
terme je crois pas qu'on puisse
développer autant de places en refusant
de dire
certaines des 350 places seront créées
dans un autre réseau celui des
résidences pour personnes âgées dit
autonome
écoutez c'est ça qui est un peu
difficile ici on trouve l'échéancier de
deux mois trop serré mais on affirme
avoir quelques places c'est une
organisation en soit là donc faut savoir
le niveau de soin qui est requis l'état
de santé de la personne
la médication si certains doutent du
fait qu'on puisse rapidement créé
beaucoup de places en hébergement de
longue durée
la plupart des experts admettre que
c'est là une stratégie incontournable si
on pense un jour réussir à désengorger
les urgences du québec
et si david gêne-t-il radio canada
montréal